Las Vegas family is asking for help and
getting any information that could lead
to the arrest of a person who killed
their loved one the deadly stabbing
happened in late November near Bonanza
near Maryland Parkway four children now
do not have their father Joshua peguero
spoke to the family they say they hope
someone might know something the
information they've been giving us has
been somewhat vague the family of Marco
hornsby's at the Las Vegas Metro Police
Department Mario Hornsby is looking for
an update on the stabbing that took his
brother's life they tell us they have a
suspect
um we don't know who the suspect is the
issue right now is locating the suspect
in response to the Hornsby family's
concerns Metro Police tell me an arrest
warrant has been issued markle's death
has left a hole in his family that is
being felt especially during this
holiday season he was always one of the
first ones to do that phone call in the
morning to wish you a a happy holiday or
a happy birthday or just see how he was
doing the Hornsby family says they just
want answers all what happened that
night November 23rd that led to the 39
year old's death and they're asking the
public to come forward with any
information so they can get some closure
here's what police tell us there was a
fight with another man at Marco's
apartment and he ended up getting
stabbed the person who did it left the
area before police arrived Howard
Hornsby says he was with his son a few
hours before he was killed I mean he was
close he always called me you know we
ride and go do what we have to do and
stuff and you're kind of hard the family
wants answers and asks if you know
anything call police or even Crime
Stoppers as you can report tips
anonymously nothing is going to bring
our brother back unfortunately but we
want to know who and whoever is
responsible for this answer for what
they did